a couple of years ago i visited silicon
valley in california and there i met
with a venture capitalist we were
talking about some great startup ideas
what the market was doing and this
person shared that every now and then
there would be a startup approaching
this vc firm and pitching an idea about
a data analytics tool and in the end of
the day it would turn out that what
these people are building was pretty
much just the new version of excel pivot
tables so this little anecdote hopefully
makes clears that pivot tables in excel
are really extremely powerful they are a
tool that you will be expected to
definitely master in any consulting
world for sure in the big mbb strategy
consulting firms like mckinsey bcg and
bain so in this video i'm going to talk
exactly about that and this is pivot
tables in excel so welcome to a new
coffee break here on my channel firm
learning my name is heineken on my
channel i want to help you to become
successful in the first years of your
career and to help you follow along in
this video i will offer the data set in
excel that we use to build this
including the tables the results of this
video as a download for you of course
for free you can access via the link in
the video description check it out to
get the data set and then follow along
while i show you the things here in this
video let's start by looking at the data
set that will serve as the basis for
your pivot table and you can imagine
this to be the data set of a retailer so
data like that and such a simple
normalized format you can commonly
obtain as an export from all your erp or
business information systems what we
have here is in the first column the
stores so as you can see here this
company has different stores that it
operates every store has the own id that
is associated to the store and then
there are lots of sales reps so here we
just have the id of the reps you can see
that there are apparently about 150
sales reps like that and then the data
is broken down by months so we have all
the months your first in the numeric
value from 1 to 11 so as you can see
here this is just data from january to
november and then you can see both the
net revenue that he was generated and
also the cost so the cost of goods solds
cox now let's include a pivot table now
i just highlighted here the whole table
and now to access pivot tables you click
here on insert and then you click on
pivot tables and then you can just go
here on from table range and if you
click on that it asks first for the
table in range and here it already then
pre-selects the range the war selected
before so as you can see this is exactly
the table that we have here until the
end here of the sheet and then it asks
where this is supposed to be inserted so
do you want to have it on a new
worksheet or an existing worksheet you
can just leave it as it and then if you
click ok you can see that here it
inserted a new tab let's maybe just call
it pivot table here in the bottom now
you can see it looks something like this
and here on the right you have all the
different variables here of the table so
for this to work properly it's important
that each column has a column header so
in the first row of each column there
needs to be yeah some header some name
if this is missing you might get an
arrow and also here all the different
variables so here for new york for
instance in every row it needs to repeat
new york so what doesn't work is that
maybe only in until here only maybe in
the first you have new york and then you
leave all this empty this doesn't work
this will give you errors this will
hinder how your pivot table works you
can see that right now the the pivot
table is just an empty field pretty much
but here on the right you have these
four key fields right so you have
filters you have columns you have rows
and you have values so let's start here
with the values bucket the idea is now
that you can just drag and drop these
variables in these four areas here so
let's start with the net revenue so
let's imagine here in values net revenue
we just want to have the number and this
note just gives me the total revenue
number in the table and we can just
verify that so if i just highlight all
of that we can see it here on the bottom
the sum of this is
6.7998 and so on yeah million euro which
is exactly the number that we have in
here of course this is not so insightful
yet so maybe let's now split it up by
different variables right and we can do
that here in the rows and maybe first
one to go for would be the stores maybe
we want to see how now the revenue
breaks down by store and we can just do
that by dragging and dropping here the
store name to the rows and now as you
can see maybe let me zoom in here a
little bit as you can see now it shows
me the revenues by store of course we
can also format this here as an
accounting number and this of course is
not great right because now it gives you
already some basic data which of course
you could also generate from this table
but it would take you some time right it
would take you like of course different
ways of doing that but it's not that
trivial usually the pivot tables are the
best ways to really create some
aggregated data aggregated things that
you can exit here now next you can use
more than one variable in the row so
let's say we want to break up the
revenue data of the stores also by
months and we can just then drag as an
additional variable here the months in
here right so now you can see here
january february march of course instead
of that we can also just drag and drop
here this other variable which just
gives the numbers and surely like this
probably not that helpful so let's take
our to the names and just the numbers or
the other way of course we can also
access both let's maybe stick with the
names for now and now you can see that
it's breaking up the data
by these variables you can see that here
i can collapse and expand this to then
just get the totals if i right click i
can also access this menu and for
instance say collect the entire field
right to collapse them all and then also
expand the entire field to get them all
again now let's also look at at some
other variables right i can pretty much
nest in here as many variables as i want
maybe i want to also look at the sales
reps and now we can break up the revenue
buy store by months and buy sales reps
maybe let's take out the months again
just to have the stores and the sales
reps the order matters right if i turn
it around if i first start with the
sales reps and then with the store name
you can see that it looks like this so
maybe not that interesting but of course
you can also just use little exercises
like this just to get a better feel for
the data so maybe you are asking
yourself is one sales rep only working
in one store or is one sales rep maybe
also working in different stores so more
than one store right and if we look at
that we can see that for each of these
sales reps there's always only one store
listed so if one state serve id would it
would be a parent would show up in more
than one stores you would have your
different rows with different stores
nested under the sales rep which is not
the case here and now maybe you want to
show the months but not here in the rows
but maybe in the columns right so this
is an additional field that you have
available here so if we just take the
months and i just drag it here in the
columns field what you can see is that
instead of breaking the fields down here
in the rows i can just show the values
here in the columns which of course
makes a lot of sense for uh for
continuous data like time data so for
other variables if we want to
put the sales reps here in the columns
this of course gives me a result right
and i can see now all the sales reps buy
stores like that but of course that's
not really intuitive to read so for this
usually you will rather
go with the columns and of course now i
can also do this here on the monthly
data as we can see right here and then
have the stores broken down by the sales
reps and then those data here in the
columns last but not least there is the
filter bucket where you can insert
filters so let's say we want to show
this data but not for all the sales reps
but only for some sales reps so i can
now drag such a variable for instance of
the state's wrap ids into the filters
now you can see that it added here this
row where i can now click on that and
now select that maybe i just want to
look at this maybe just for the sales
rep with the id number one and that's
apparently a sales rep that maybe isn't
with the company anymore so let's pick
another one maybe with the sales rep
number five and here we can see this
person only worked in the store new york
in april and july of course you can also
go and select multiple items by
selecting several sales reps just your
randomly select sum and then we can get
all the data for that of course i can do
this with other variables as well let's
take that out and maybe let's say that i
only want to show let's take that out
again i want to show the revenue data
for the stores but not for all months
but only for some months right so i can
go in here and i'll just look at the
number for january or for february right
or maybe i want to show it for january
to march what is also often handy is
that you cannot only report on the sum
of a variable like the revenue but
sometimes you also want to look into
some other types of reports here right
so then you right click on a variable
here like the sum of the revenue you
click on value field settings and now
you can see that you can report all
different types of things so count
average max min product and so on and so
forth so i think in this instance this
doesn't make too much sense what we
could for instance maybe do is look at
the max and now it reports the highest
revenue figure that it finds for the
store in the table and if you remember
how the table is set up probably this
would mean is that this number
represents the highest monthly revenue
that one sales rep created in this store
so again this depends a bit on how here
the base table is set up often the sum
though will be the go go-to format that
you want to go for indeed now let's look
into some layouting considerations so
maybe this example again where you had
the stores and then the month not in the
filters but here in the rows so of
course while this is a great view
sometimes you also want to have such a
data set as an output than in a
normalized table format because we can
see here that now the column a contains
mixed information right it contains both
the name of the store and also the id of
the month which is not always favorable
if then you want to do some other things
with the data so what you can do to fix
it is right click here on the table and
then go on pivot table options and then
under display you find here the option
classical pivot
table layout enables dragging of fields
and so on so usually i like to have this
activated because what this is doing it
separates all the different information
in different columns which is what you
need if then in the end with such a
pivot table you want to create a
normalized table format again which can
be helpful for instance with building
dashboards so if you watched my other
video on creating dashboards in excel
you know what i'm talking about i will
link it somewhere about here this
technique is really helpful to for
instance then with some if formulas and
so on build some quite dynamic
dashboards check out the video if you
want to learn more about that you can
also do things like deleting or taking
out here the subtotal so we can see that
here we have the subtotal for the store
name we can take it out of course
inserting again if we want and then
again for the sake of having normalized
clean tables often what you need to do
is that you want to repeat the label
berlin right so you don't want the store
name only to appear in the first row but
you want it to appear in all the rows
again in order to have a nice normalized
table format so if you want to do that
just to right click click field settings
and then you can do here at layout and
print to go on repeat item labels you
need to tick the check mark and then you
will have it repeated throughout the
table again you might want then also to
take out the subtotal again to have a
very clean
normalized table to work with so let's
continue and let's say we might want to
do some more right we not only want to
work here with the revenue data but we
also want to show some margin
information by store and by
month or maybe let's not do it by month
but by sales rip right so we might want
to compare the different margins that
the sales reps have available here so
let's take out the filters to show all
the reps in all the stores and of course
the variable that we have available here
are the cost so i can now drag the cost
also here in the values area to not show
both the net revenue and the cost but
now one thing maybe let's start first
without the reps to simplify now here we
have the revenue and the cost data one
thing that of course typically you would
like to do is you would now take the
revenue and subtract the cost in order
to get to the margin to the gross
margin the problem is that you cannot
really work with like this with pivot
tables because if you just copy that
over
as you can see it does not really then
go here and then adjust the formula
accordingly so that doesn't work there
are some other ways to like you know
make it work you know let's not go too
much into that of course another
alternative would be you can just take
the table and you can copy just the
values right you can copy the values and
then of course you just have the data
you're extracting next to you you can of
course also format this in an accounting
format and then of course you can do
whatever you like so you can do the same
calculations and then of course also the
style of working with formulas does work
to make that work but that's also not
the real way how these pivot tables are
intended to work because of course now
if you change anything here this doesn't
adjust automatically but sometimes this
can be a little heck to the very quick
and straightforward way do your own
calculations so instead what you can do
to really make this work in pivot tables
is to use something that is called
calculated fields right so if you click
on the pivot table analyze so you need
to highlight the pivot table for this to
show up you go on fields items and sets
you go on calculated fields now you can
just create your own additional field so
let's say we want to have the gross
margin let's first start an absolute so
in euro and in order to that here it
gives me all the fields that are loaded
into the pivot table that i can now work
with and of course the gross margin is
the net revenue so i click here on
insert field and then you can see that
it's added to the formula and i press a
minus and now here press cox so cost of
goods sold as an additional one and now
i add this and now you can see that i
have here the gross margin in percent
available and now let's do once more
right let's even add an additional field
let's now say we want to have the gross
margin
in percentage and of course this would
be then the gross margin absolute that
we just added divided by the net revenue
insert to now give us this additional
field now we press ok now you can see
that it already added that here to the
table of course here the percentage we
will likely want to form it as a
percentage indeed to make it look like
something like this i think this is
already first interesting analysis so
now see how different margins of these
stores compared to each other and the
great thing is that as soon as you have
added those variables it's calculated
fields you can do all the things we did
with the pivot table already right so
you can add them to the tables you can
then also drill down with it with all
the other additional variables so maybe
you know let's just look at the
percentage figures then we probably also
don't need the cogs anymore let's say we
want to break this down by the different
sales reps so here by the different
sales reps of the store so we can see
what their revenue is we can see what
their margin is the known average they
created maybe we don't need the stores
we just have the sales reps here and of
course you can also do things like
sorting this whole thing by the margin
so here let's sort by the margin from
largest to smallest of course you know
we have some funny data and he also said
so apps probably didn't do a lot of
revenue maybe just with some assistance
working there for a couple of days but
here we can see that there are some reps
which also more significant results so
this person was doing more than 30 000
euro in revenue and had a margin of 64
so there are reps like that that are
doing quite well and then of course we
can all go down to the bottom of the
table where we have margins we have reps
we're doing 60 000 euro and have a
really low margin right and this of
course would be interesting conduct some
basic analyses like this have an
understanding of the data and then to
work with this in this way but there's
another thing that is very powerful that
you can do with pivot tables and this is
to use them to create dashboards in
excel to create dynamic dashboards in
excel so to make that work let's look at
an example let's maybe work with the
store names so let's imagine want to
make a dashboard that helps me to slice
into revenue and margin data for the
store so let's add here the revenue and
the margins and the first thing in order
to move there that's already pretty cool
is if you click on pivot table analyze
there is the option here to insert
slicers right you can insert slicers now
it asks you what type of slicers you
want to have so let's say we want to
have slicers
for the months and maybe also for the
store names so let's add
both of them and you can see that now it
added these additional panels that you
can hear freely position in your table
what this is doing not just on the table
that you can now select for instance
this data just for january or just for
february or just for march so in the end
of the day it's nothing else but filters
you can also tick several of them but
it's a bit of a more visual way and this
can be then very easily used as an input
mechanism
for the dashboards that you want to
create because the next thing that you
can do is also to insert charts so if
you click here on the pivot table pivot
table analyze it provides you the
opportunity to insert a pivot chart as
it's called and maybe let's just go for
the standard clustered columns so here
by store gives me the net revenue in the
gross margin of course you can go with
any other chart as well and it's a
special type of chart that automatically
adjusts the content to all the things we
have shown here in the pivot table
because now what you can do
is that if you here now change this it
automatically changes all the contents
of your stores as well and of course you
can highlight both right you can say let
me just show the data for berlin
for may or for april or for march or
maybe i want to have different stores so
berlin dusseldorf and london and this is
really the the core of how you would
build dashboards so if you would want to
make a great dashboard out of that you
could now create all types of pivot
tables like that often then you do a
distinct tab where you hide all your
pivot tables and then you have an output
tab where you have all kinds of charts
like this then of course you can format
the charts make them look a little bit
better you can also format these slicers
to make them look really cool really
great so that's i don't want to go into
detail here too much because of course
you can just really go like spend lots
of time talking about this but then you
have some controls for the users who can
just drill down here in the data select
the date select the stores and this is
really a powerful way on how you can
enable your users to in a very intuitive
way with the help of pivot tables drill
down into your data sets so there are
different ways of building dashboards
with excel pivot tables for sure is one
very effective of them you can have a
full playlist with excel videos
including one video on how to build
dashboards without pivot tables actually
in the video that i created there let me
know in the comments if you would be
interested in another video on how to
build dashboards with pivot tables and
of course check out the other videos in
the playlist to learn more about excel
so if you have any questions or this or
other tips you want to share on excel or
pivot tables yourself feel free to leave
a comment in the comment section also
big big thanks to all the members of the
channel thank you for supporting the
course here this is very much
appreciated if you took any value out of
this video at all please hit the like
button for the youtube algorithm and
also subscribe to stay up to date on all
my content and also turn on the
notification bell my name is heiner here
with these weekly videos every single
saturday see you again next week until
then all the best to you and bye bye